[Musique]
jhonattan vegas
put à cliquer qu'est ce que le put à
cliquer en route il put à cliquer ça
revient à inciter à cliquer sur une
vidéo ce que je fais et de ne pas
traiter ce sujet dans la vidéo ce que je
ne fais pas donc il me reprochait
parfois de faire des petites [ __ ] à
cliquer
alors je n'en fais pas alors si je ne
fais pas du pit à cliquer qu'est ce que
je fais j'ai cherché pendant longtemps à
comprendre comment fonctionne et
l'algorithme de youtube
j'ai fini par comprendre comment il
fonctionnait en partie d'ailleurs je
vous ai fait une série de vidéos dessus
l'année dernière dans cette vidéo je
vous donnais 10 astuces indispensables
pour créer sa chaîne youtube
comment avoir vaut mille premiers
abonnés dans cette vidéo je vous donnais
les bonnes astuces et les bonnes
pratiques pour écrire un titre aux
petits oignons tu t'es c'est beaucoup de
titres de miniatures de différents
combats pour mes vidéos et qu'est ce que
j'ai appris que l'émotion est reine
écrire en ont dit c'est tout un art faut
délivrer des informations sans en dire
trop
sinon il n'y a aucun intérêt à regarder
la vidéo par exemple la vidéo sur le nom
du nouvel iphone
le titre de la vidéo était on connaît le
nom du prochain iphone si je vous avais
fait pour titre l'iphone 2018
s'appellera iphone ça n'a globalement
aucun intérêt parce que dans ce type là
je donne directement l'info principale
de la vidéo donc pourquoi aller regarder
une vidéo
alors vous avez déjà la réponse ici
c'est là globalement aucun intérêt et au
final ce titre là ressemble davantage à
un tweet
car un petit de vidéos sur youtube un
bon petit doit annoncer ce qu'on va
retrouver dans la vidéo sans en dire
trop mais surtout le titre doit susciter
de l'intérêt
et souvent ça bosse sur une émotion et
la curiosité reste leader dans ce
domaine
donc ma vidéo on connaît le nom du
prochain iphone ne pourrai très
clairement pas s'appeler l'iphone 2018
s'appellera iphone
le petit doit inciter à la curiosité
d'où un titre associé à la miniature
l'iphone 2018 s'appellera propre poids
car le titre travaille toujours concert
avec sa miniature donc dans cette vidéo
le titre en parfaite adéquation avec la
miniature donc pour le coup pas du tout
à cliquer ces incitatifs
alors qu'en est il du contenu le contenu
je vous l'accordé devant imperfectible
mais ça globalement il le sera toujours
ces trois derniers mois j'ai énormément
travaillé en dehors du tube parce
qu'aujourd'hui je ne vienne pas encore
d'avis et youtube
donc j'avais des délais de tournage très
serré j'ai dû faire des vidéos dans un
temps très court et j'ai monté au fur et
à mesure
alors pourquoi faire autant de vidéos et
sortir des vidéos tous les jours
simplement parce que je suis un
passionné énormément le sujet qui
m'intéresse c'est que ces sujets jambes
et les partager avec vous tout comme les
dernières germans j'ai tourné de façon
presque industrielle j'ai tourné quatre
cinq six vidéos par jour
ensuite c'est un déplacement et je
mentais une vidéo chaque soin et vous la
trouviez le lendemain directement sur
youtube
ça explique pourquoi il ya énormément de
vidéos avec des plans face calmes et que
la production forcément il n'est pas la
plus originale mais rassurez-vous parce
qu'en ce moment je passe énormément de
temps sur l'écriture la prod
je prépare un nouveau format pour la
rentrée est là pour ça devrait envoyer
du bois
donc restez connectés alors le format
parlant de ça le format c'est très
intéressant ça fait des mois que je
cherche le bon format le format qui me
plaît le format qui m'intéresse
j'ai pas encore trouvé exactement la
formule qui m'intéresse le plus je sais
déjà ce que j'aime pas je sais déjà ce
que je veux pas faire et j'entre
aperçoit ce que je vais faire et là où
je veux aller
donc c'est tout le travail aujourd'hui
que je fais deux pré prod et d'écriture
pour la rentrée pour vraiment avoir le
meilleur format à partir du mois de
septembre
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je tiens à vous
remercier d'être toujours plus nombreuse
toujours plus nombreux quel que soit
votre position géographique
vous êtes très nombreux à regarder en
france très nombreux en belgique au
maroc au canada en algérie dans tous les
pays francophones au sénégal au congo
on va même jusqu aux états unis on coup
c'est un peu ma francophones mais il ya
aussi beaucoup d'endroits francophones
aux etats-unis au brésil
enfin il ya une liste de pays qui
complètement dingue et c'était vraiment
tous à vous remercier d'être là de me
soutenir de me laisser des commentaires
alors même si j'ai pas forcément le
temps d'y répondre que j'étais très très
très très speed ces derniers temps ge
mais en moi j'ai toujours un coup d'oeil
je regardais ça me permet effectivement
de pouvoir réagir ce soit au travers de
vidéos comme celle ci on coud
typiquement ou alors on vous répondront
à vos commentaires directement de
l'argent vous pouvez demander d'où est
ce que vous êtes vous là tout de suite
qu'à regarder
laissez moi en commentaire votre ville
et votre pays
s'intéressant joué le jeu honnête et le
c'est vraiment très intéressant je suis
vraiment curieux parce que moi j'ai des
statistiques de youtube
j'ai une carte du monde j'ai la liste
des pays mais connaître exactement votre
emplacement par ville et par payer ça
m'intéresse d'autant plus que d'ici
quelques moines qui quelques bons mois
on sera plus en plus nombreux sur la
chaîne
et dès qu'on passera un palier à six
chiffres il se peut qu'on se fasse 1
rencontre tous en ce moment pour
inscrire un grand pique nique on
pourrait se dire je sais pas quoi dire à
cette chose à réfléchir donc en plus il
faut vraiment savoir d'où est ce que
vous êtes et où est ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'on se rencontre
ça pourrait être cool conclusion est ce
que je fais du pit à cliquer non est ce
que je fais des titres qui incite au
clic oui est-ce que du coup je respecte
mes abonnés bien sûr que oui un grand
oui évidemment au contraire je les aime
les abonnés et même ceux qui ne sont pas
encore allés venez pas là pour se faire
un gros câlin en trouver un on se fait
de gros efforts
alors n'oubliez pas si les titres sont
incitatifs sais pas pour vous prendre
pour des cons parce que très clairement
vous ne l'êtes pas d'eux je ne le pense
pas et 2,3 certainement je veux pas le
faire mais juste parce que la règle
youtube l'obligent pour vos vidéos soit
vu qu'elle soit découverte qu'elle
puisse intéresser qu il puisse y avoir
du monde qui le regarde il faut
forcément susciter l'émotion suscité
l'intérêt et d'où l'intérêt de faire des
titres qui sont incitatifs après le
contenu je suis d'accord il est
affective
il ya toujours des choses à revoir des
choses à améliorer jour convient
parfaitement je travaille dessus
énormément et voilà je vais faire cette
petite mise au point
merci en tout cas vous d'avoir présent
de garder cette vidéo n'oublie pas
marqué en commentaire d'ouest que vous
menez que je pouvais marquer pas
d'autres commentaires dites moi ce que
vous en pensez si vous êtes d'accord
avec moi si vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord avec moi ce que vous pensez
aussi du format si vous trouvé
intéressant qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez voir de quoi vous avez
envie qu est ce qui vous plaît qu'est ce
qui vous plaît pas vous marquez tout ça
pour le coup c'est l'occasion merci à
vous je vous embrasse soyez sages
prenez soin de vous